[Musique]
mais bonsoir à tous mardi 2 octobre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv
60,18 l'essentiel de l'actualité locale
en 26 minutes
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition après la ryder cup le golf
continue de faire des émules dans les
yvelines hier deux sections de ce sport
ont été inaugurés à guyancourt elle
ouvre dans la ville au collège des
saules et à celui des prêts de montigny
le bretonneux une quarantaine d'élèves
va bénéficier de trois heures de golf
par semaine et les lycéens du
département vont pouvoir jauger leurs
connaissances historiques
le jeu concours les cracks de l'histoire
vient d'être lancé un quiz en ligne
jusqu'au 5 novembre prochain est le
projet telle initiative de l'association
versailles à histoire de lire nous
recevons l'une de ses membres
anaïs de haut de six lits enfin des
relais de la country pour la bonne cause
une fête aux couleurs américaines se
tenait ce week end à bali organisé par
l'association un geste en plus
l'événement avait pour but de récolter
des fonds pour financer à des projets
autour du handicap et nous parlerons
également du handicap avec notre
deuxième invité de cap emploi 78
l'organisme co organise ce vendredi un
forum
andy recrutement c'est dans le cadre de
la semaine du handicap à montigny le
bretonneux à la ryder cup continue de
répandre son golf dans les yvelines deux
collèges ont ouvert des sections
sportives golf les saules de guyancourt
et le collège des prés à montigny le
bretonneux pour l'inauguration de ces
classes hier à guyancourt la fédération
française de golf le comité
départemental et l'éducation nationale
en ont profité pour signer une
convention et continuer ainsi la
démocratisation de ce sport dans le
département reportage de marie lehn yapi
shiloh la ryder cup passé on pense déjà
à la suite dans les yvelines la
fédération française de golf la
direction des services de l'éducation
nationale et les élus ont inauguré lundi
deux nouvelles sections golf dans les
collèges de nouvelles classes qui
répondent à la logique de
démocratisation de la discipline lancée
dès 2008 nous étions un peu dans un bar
donc finalement dans le département avec
près de 32 sites golfique et puis aucune
section sportive scolaire
donc aujourd'hui nous en sommes à deux
nous comptons évidemment prolonger cette
dynamique
le golfeur professionnel français
michaël lorenzo vera est le parrain de
ces sections yvelinoise une quarantaine
de collégiens de tous les niveaux
peuvent dès à présent bénéficier de
trois heures de golf par semaine mais
nous aux athlètes et champion de golf de
demain sont là et lorsque je vois ces
jeunes naturellement avoir un bon swing
de golf taper dans la balle avec
beaucoup de naturel je suis contente
qu'ils découvrent enfin notre sport
avant d'en faire des champions
l'objectif est surtout de démocratiser
la pratique la section sportive leur
ouvre la voie à la licence unss des
heures d'entraînement supplémentaire le
mercredi pour les plus motivés et des
compétitions cdl qui dans l'ensemble
sont assez attentif et qui ont envie de
progresser parce que c'est vraiment
basée sur la motivation est parti au
moment où on avait motivé je dire il
réussit plus vite que n'importe quel
autre élève l'éducation nationale s'est
fixé pour objectif l'ouverture de 4000
sections sportives supplémentaires dans
toute la france d'ici 2024 et on
reparlera collège tout à l'heure dans ce
journal avec une opération nettoyage de
la nature l an passé saint quentin en
yvelines lançait son implication dans le
dispositif sport sur ordonnance c'est
une activité physique adaptée est
prescrite par un médecin dans
l'agglomération l'institut de promotion
de la santé porte l'initiative les
premières sessions ont eu lieu en avril
et ont repris le 17 septembre
mélanie poquet
des étirements qui semble facile mais
pour ces participants la maladie ou
l'âge les rendre plus compliquée ils
prennent leur deuxième cours d'activités
sportives adaptées pour pouvoir en fait
être acquérir de l'autonomie pour
pouvoir garder une forme malgré que
gérard bientôt 80 ans et je veux rester
en forme le plus longtemps possible
le sport sur ordonnance inscrit dans la
loi de modernisation de santé de 2016
l'activité physique est prescrite comme
thérapies non médicamenteuses
ça va être une pratique qu'on va
modifier pour que les gens qui ont des
pathologies ou des troubles physiques
soit capable de les faire sans danger
pour eux et pour leur psyché donc c'est
un petit peu plus compliqué parce que ce
sont des personnes qu'on doit surveiller
avec beaucoup d'attention mais ce sont
des personnes qui peuvent reprendre goût
au sport saint quentin en yvelines le
lance sur son territoire en novembre
2010 est sa demande
la construction de ce dispositif ce port
sans ordonnance l'implication de
différents acteurs les médecins bien sûr
mais aussi les clubs sportifs qui
doivent se certifier à l'activité
physique adaptée et parallèlement dans
la construction elle ce dispositif qui
au niveau régional se décline sous la
forme prescrit forme actuellement quatre
créneaux pour quinze personnes sont
proposés et déjà victimes de leur succès
les cycles vont de 12 à 15 séances mais
on peut déjà faire de l'activité
physique à la maison il est recommandé
de marché au minimum 30 minutes par jour
dans l'actualité du jour de la politique
avec la signature ce midi d'un faune
interdépartemental d'investissement
entre les sept départements franciliens
elle est présidente ces collectivités se
sont réunis dans les locaux de
l'assemblée des départements de france à
paris pour créer un établissement public
interdépartemental
l'objectif c'est de renforcer la
solidarité financière entre ces
départements alors pour nous expliquer
ce nouveau dispositif nicolas landry
nous a rejoint un plateau bonsoir
nicolas monso grégory de la rédaction de
tv 78 alors pouvez vous nous expliquer
en quoi consiste ce fonds
d'investissement inter départementale et
bien c'est une première dans l'histoire
des collectivités territoriales en
france la création d'un fonds
d'investissement entre sept départements
ce fonds sera abondé d'un montant de 150
millions d'euros en 2019 un financement
annuel pris en charge par les sept
collectivités franciliennes et une
contribution des yvelines à hauteur de
27 millions d'euros
deuxième contributeur ce département et
objectif financer des projets
d'aménagement dans les domaines des
transports ou encore des infrastructures
sportives
autre décision prise ce matin nicolas le
renforcement d'un dispositif de
péréquation vous allez nous expliquer
les termes dans un instant alors ce
dispositif c'est un fonds de solidarité
pour les départements de la région ile
de france et bien grégory comme vous
l'avez dit je vais d'abord expliquer le
terme péréquation regardez cette
infographie
prenons l'exemple d'un département doté
de ressources financières importantes
notamment grâce aux recettes fiscales
cette collectivité va verser une somme
dans un fonds dit de péréquation et ce
fonds va permettre une redistribution à
un département doté de ressources
minimes avec des recettes fiscales
moindres
vous l'avez compris ce dispositif permet
de réduire les inégalités de richesse
entre les collectivités et concrètement
comment se passe cette péréquation dans
le cadre de ce fonds de solidarité pour
les départements franciliens
alors vous l'avez dit au début le fonds
de solidarité pour les départements de
la région d'île de france existent déjà
la péréquation atteint 60 millions
d'euros par an les présidents des sept
départements d'île de france ont décidé
de la doubler à 120 millions d'euros par
an conséquence les deux départements
contributeurs seulement les yvelines et
les hauts-de-seine vont voir leur
montant augmenter pour le 78 le montant
passe de 2,3 millions d'euros à 6 7
millions merci nicolas de nous aider à y
voir plus clair sur ces sujets complexes
à montigny le bretonneux c'est la
quinzième semaine du handicap sept jours
d'animations de sensibilisation et
d'action pour faire évoluer les regards
sur le handicap est la municipalité
s'associe avec pôle emploi et cap emploi
soixante dix huit pour organiser à cette
occasion est la troisième édition du
forum
andy recrutement c'est ce vendredi de 9h
à 12h à la mairie pour en parler parce
qu'elle bréheret bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes chargé de mission handicap et
employeurs pour cap emploi 60 18 alors
cet organisme a pour but de permettre et
favoriser l'embauché des personnes en
situation de
hop première question quel est le
principe y quels sont les objectifs de
ce forum andy recrutement au niveau de
pouvoir permettre de mettre en relation
des entreprises et des personnes dont
des candidats en situation de handicap
pour afin de pouvoir disons faciliter
leur insertion professionnelle et de
pouvoir faire des rencontres au travers
des changes mais également que les
personnes puissent
candidate et déposer leur cv
et puis faire des demandes peut-être de
stage de découverte métier enfin c'est
assez vaste peut-être brisé quelques
barrières ils ont du mal aujourd'hui à
se rencontrer ces demandeurs d'emploi
handicapés et ses entreprises
alors oui c'est pas forcément quelque
chose qui est évident c'est que très
bien que le pourcentage du travail et
handicapés en recherche d'emploi est
plus important que les personnes
c'est le taux de chômage chez les
personnes handicapées exactement donc ça
fait à peu près un peu plus de 2 fois 2
donc effectivement toute initiative est
bonne à prendre et on remercie la mairie
montigny-le-bretonneux pour pouvoir
avoir ils ont à ses initiatives et
l'idée c'est que ça se fasse si j'ai
bien compris dans un climat convivial
cette rencontre ça va conviviale
donc on est avec pôle emploi évidemment
et donc la mairie de montigny
donc on fait
au travers d'ateliers de rencontres donc
les candidats sont évidemment invités
donc il ya un petit déjeuner au départ
et puis ensuite ils sont dirigés vers
les entreprises auxquelles en fait ils
peuvent distribuer leurs cv mais
également présenté leurs candidatures
en quelques minutes et ensuite on il ya
trois ateliers qui sont organisées par
le pôle emploi par nous-mêmes qui donc
on va présenter le handicap comment
parler de ce handicap également notre
offre de services et un clapet emploi ça
m et puis également un atelier harris
pour destiné aux personnes
malentendantes et souvent hors la loi
oblige depuis 1997 les 17 pardon les
entreprises de plus de 20 salariés
employés au moins 6% de travailleurs
handicapés plus de vingt ans après on
l'a dit tout à l'heure ce taux de
chômage chez les personnes handicapées
et à 19% c'est quasiment le double du
taux de chômage global et seront ce que
vous avez quand même un regard positif
est ce qu'il ya une évolution positive
tout de même sur le travail des
personnes handicapées regard positif
lorsqu'on fait ce métier oui en revanche
effectivement c'est jamais assez de
toute manière on a toujours besoin
d'événements de pouvoir effectivement de
sensibiliser les entreprises notamment
les collectivités de tout pour pour
faciliter l'emploi des personnes en
situation de handicap c'est la raison
pour laquelle le nouvel obs donc cap
emploi ça met donc vers et dans l'emploi
disons qu'on s'emploie encourager disons
cette initiative toutes les initiatives
sont bons à prendre donc au niveau des
candidats mais également au niveau des
employeurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
cet événement de faire rencontrer les
deux est plus très pertinentes au
travers cet événement du forum
andy recrutement est ce qu'il ya des
retours positifs et ce que concrètement
ça a permis d embauche alors oui
l'année dernière donc on peut quantifier
on peut avoir des chiffres 144 visiteurs
52 personnes invitées par notre
organisme et cap emploi et 13
entreprises étaient présentes
ça a débouché t sur quatre embauches
les trois stages à l'appel du ps ump les
périodes de mise en situation en milieu
professionnel
cette année on est partis de l'hypothèse
d'aller chercher des offres et donc
d'inviter des entreprises sur lesquelles
le candidat pouvait répondre donc
on a un objectif évidemment de doubler
un petit peu nos résultats qui est
peut-être
qui est peut-être
très optimiste mais on va s'y employer
en tout cas depuis la première édition
de ce forum en dire crûment ça évolue
bien sûr bien sûr on évolue avec les
entreprises voire besoin le besoin du
territoire très important et donc cette
année on a effectivement on est partie
du territoire est également encore une
fois de la demande de nos de notre offre
là l'offre des personnes des cv pour
pouvoir au mieux en fait cher
correspondent les demandes des
entreprises mais également
les candidatures et les profils des
questions pratiques
ce qu'on peut s'inscrire comment y
participer à ceux formant des
recrutements est bien égale est tout
simplement ils vont y aura des
inscriptions au niveau alors ce qu'on
rentrera en fait au niveau des ateliers
et pourquoi pas effectivement signé sa
présence au niveau du pôle emploi et de
services de toute manière on a envoyé
des invitations mais je pense qu'on peut
librement j'ai pas vérifié l'info mais
je pense qu'il ne doit pas y avoir de
problème merci pascal bréheret d'avoir
été avec nous je vous remercie
chargé de mission handicap et employeurs
pour cap emploi 78 ce forum andy
recrutement se tient ce vendredi de 9h à
12h à la mairie de montigny le
bretonneux pour retrouver toutes les
informations sur ce forum est aussi le
programme complet de cette semaine du
handicap à montigny le bretonneux rendez
vous sur le site internet de la ville
retour à présent sur cette opération
opération nettoyons la nature 185 élèves
de 6e du collège le village de trappes
ont pris à gants et sacs poubelles pour
débarrasser à lille de loisirs de ces
déchets est une activité ludique pour
sensibiliser les jeunes à
l'environnement et au développement
durable un sujet de marylène iapichino
donc ça c'est notre sac recyclage
quelqu'un peut le prendre
ok ce vendredi matin pour les 6e du
collège le village de trappes
les cours se faisait dans la nature
l'île des loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines l'eure a ouvert ses portes pour
se faire faire une mise en beauté et le
fonds pour la nature et en même temps ça
les salles et sensibilise ça leur
apprend les bonnes habitudes même pas
jeter on leur donne des petits conseils
prendre l'habitude de jeter dans les
poubelles ou mettre dans la poche en
attendant de trouver une poubelle en
fait des bouteilles du plus qu'un simple
ramassage il s'agit aussi de les
éveiller au tri des déchets les papiers
là là dans la poubelle non recyclables
et les bouteilles dans la poubelle
recyclable on a ramassé des bouteilles
de verre on a ramassé du du à papier du
plastique et mais on a ramassé des
bouffons cela fait trois ans que le
collège organise cette opération à lille
de loisirs avec une poursuite en classe
pour que les bonnes habitudes
s'installent tout les sixièmes participe
tous les ans comme ça à terme le but est
que tous les élèves du collège effet
cette activité pour qu'ils respectent
après au collège aussi les règles de
recyclage en une matinée les jeunes
trappistes ont amassé 900 litres
d'emballages recyclables 600 litres de
bouteilles en verre et une vingtaine de
sacs les déchets divers prochaine étape
pour les collégiens la visite d'un
centre de recyclage pour continuer le
tri les quarante mille lycéens des
yvelines eux pourront tester leur niveau
d'histoire le jeu concours les cracks de
l'histoire a été lancé hier c'est
jusqu'au 5 novembre
un quiz en ligne avec des lots à la clé
pour en parler à lise de haut de six
gibbons soir bonsoir
vous êtes en charge des relations
scolaire pour histoire de lire alors
cette association a imaginé ce jeu
concours
avant d'en parler parlons de votre
association de ses actions histoire de
lire qui organise chaque année c'est un
rendez vous traditionnel à versailles
c'est le salon du livre d'histoire au
mois de novembre 26 24 25 novembre pour
cette année l'association histoire de
lire regroupe des passionnés d'histoire
et qu'ils sont convaincus qu'il faut
transmettre au plus grand nombre cette
cet amour de l'histoire nationale
tendant dans cet entretien on présentera
peut-être les grandes lignes de ce
prochain salon du livre d'histoire
vous êtes venu en tout cas pour parler
de ce jeu concours les cracks de
l'histoire pour pourquoi lancer ce jeu
auprès des lycéens alors parce que nous
avons à coeur de rendre
l'histoire plus accessible
et plus vivante et de sensibiliser le
public les jeunes publics
si l'art et la relation au livre et à la
lecture chez l'enfant est assez courante
c'est une pratique courante
nous constatons qu'à partir de
l'adolescence les enfants décrochent
face notamment aux diktats du digital
donc à travers le jeu nous souhaitons
que l'adolescent renoue avec l'histoire
avec le livre
et donc avec ce jeu on rentre en contact
individuellement avec chaque joueur de
manière ludique et pourquoi c'est
important quelle est l'importance
finalement de l'histoire
pourquoi en faire la promotion pourquoi
cette histoire la rendre plus accessible
auprès des jeunes alors l'importance de
l'histoire c'est un vaste sujet pour
savoir où l'on va il faut savoir d'où
l'on vient
notre indice notre identité individuelle
comme celle des peuples
s'inscrit dans notre temps bref la
transmission nous construit dans le cas
par exemple du journalisme à comprendre
mieux l'actualité du jour on va
décrypter l'actualité par exemple louis
en reliant aux petits comme aux grands
événements au à nos ancêtres comme aux
figures les plus illustres l'histoire
avec un grand h permet cet enracinement
et du cou
cette donne cette expérience cette
connaissance du passé qui éclaire le
présent
alors comment s'est monté ce
jeu-concours quels sont les partenaires
qui se sont joints vous voulez vous
citer un exemple parce que je le
trouvais intéressant d'un jeune avec qui
je discutais récemment des centaines
l'histoire et qui me disait si j'ai pas
étudié la démocratie
les monarchies la lenteur la démocratie
depuis l'antiquité les monarchies les
régimes politiques et les régimes
politiques au fil des siècles les
dictatures
comment puis je comprends l'enjeu de
voter par exemple ça explique claude
chose et c'est très important on l'a
compris alors le projet de ce concours
les cracks de l'histoire commence et il
monte alors c'est un projet qui est né
de rencontres avec le monde des
enseignants qui sont lassés du manque de
concentration des jeunes qui sont un peu
à l'affût d'initiatives innovantes
d'initiatives dans l'air du temps qui
sont un petit peu original et on a donc
eu des échanges très nourris avec
l'académie de versailles en particulier
notamment avec l'inspection d'histoire
et ce projet a donc vu le jour l'année
dernière
les questionnaires puisqu'on a trois ont
fait l'objet d'un travail très dense
toutes les questions étaient valides et
revalider revalider voilà donc elles ont
été bien pensé sur le principe c'est
combien de questions c'est sur quelle
période
alors ces vingt questions par par niveau
de classe chaque donc les seconds en
vacation les premières les terminales
donc fin de trois questionnaires
différend qui porte sur le programme de
l'année précédente
donc les secondes sur programme de
l'année troisième etc voilà ils ont une
21e questions ouvertes aussi qui se
traitent en quelques minutes en quelques
mots est-ce que vous avez un exemple de
question des caisses et des questions
ils sont très variés
cela peut-être sur la ligne maginot sur
le gag sur l'otan la pérestroïka
l'antiparlementarisme
le régime politique née de
de la révolution de février 1948 c'est
très varié les périodes sont variées
elles sont vraiment calé aussi sur les
programmes de chaque chaque niveau de
classe e on arrive bientôt à la fin de
cet entretien comment on y joue à ce jeu
et quels sont les lots à gagner
on s'inscrit sur les cracks points
histoire de lire point fr donc ils ont
quinze minutes 10 minutes pour les vingt
questions cinq minutes pour la 21ème
question beaucoup de partenaires se sont
associés à cette aventure
une centaine de lots sont à gagner
d'accord
donc délivre enfin la route va t'on les
éditions faton pour des abonnements
larousse pour des livres
et d'autres partenaires qui nous réserve
des surprises avec des lots originaux
voilà alors il nous reste attractif
surtout un tout petit peu de temps pour
parler d'un autre rendez-vous le salon
du livre d'histoire qui se déroulera à
versailles les 24 et 25 novembre
qu'est-ce que vous préparer pour cette
édition aux visiteurs alors déjà c'est
pour les jeunes
ils viendront chercher leurs lots sur le
salon voilà ce sera l'occasion pour eux
de venir aussi à la rencontre des
auteurs des auteurs comme
quel son prénom daniel bilalian michael
lonsdale
il y en a cent soixante d'en reparler de
ce salon du livre d'histoire
et si vous êtes lycéen pour participer
donc au jeu concours
les cracks de l'histoire vous avez
jusqu'au 5 novembre et le site internet
qui s'est affichée qui s'affiche encore
elle les cracks points histoire de lire
point fr merci à nice 2-2 s'agit d'avoir
été avec nous et merci à la région et en
particulier à valérie pécresse qui a
permis ce jeu d'attenté d'être alors
peut-être en ligne depuis l'année
dernière pour la deuxième année je vous
êtes en charge des relations scolaire
pour l'association histoire de lire
c'est l'heure maintenus
du coup de coeur culture nous a rejoints
en plateau mélanie poquet bon soir sans
grégory
alors pour votre coup de coeur culture
de la semaine on va parler hip hop jazz
et soul
et oui trois styles un artiste syl
johnson alors le nom ne vous dit
peut-être rien mais syl johnson chante
en fait depuis 20 ans il a 20 ans de
carrière et un titres célèbres qui est
sorti en 1999 écouter
eh oui angela sly johnson fait partie
des saïan supa crew
mais il chante en fait en solo depuis
2007 qui est aussi la date de séparation
du groupe
alors depuis 2007 ce mélanie des albums
de nombreuses collaborations avec
camille erik truffaz oxmo puccino et une
tournée qui passe par les yvelines et
oui il sera sur la scène de la batterie
de guyancourt ce samedi le 6 octobre
pour ce concert il prépare des surprises
notamment des extraits de son nouvel
album qui est prévu lui pour 2019 et
notamment skins qui est son dernier
titre avant d'écouter un extrait il nous
en dit un peu plus ce qui me parle en
fait de de cet épisode en école primaire
pour je me retrouvais avec tous les
autres enfants dans la cour de récré et
es12 malheureusement traité de sale noir
voilà et c'est ce jour là
moi je les prix comme ça que j'ai appris
j'étais noir du coup donc je raconte
cette histoire
dans le morceau ce qui me prêtent alors
pourchassé matin
[Musique]
pour en découvrir bien plus la johnson
se donne donc rendez vous le 6 octobre à
20h30
et c'est à la batterie de guyancourt
merci mélanie pour cette chronique on
vous retrouve dans un instant pour votre
émission du mardi le 7-8 culture mais
avant de refermer ce journal cet
événement avait pour but de récolter des
fonds en faveur du handicap le week-end
dernier l'association un geste en plus
réunissait à l'institut d'éducation
motrice de bahia voitures anciennes et
harley ambiance festive à l'américaine
pour la bonne cause retour avec marylène
iapichino et iv hub stand berger
l'institut d'éducation motrice de bailly
était festif et aux couleurs américaines
samedi l'association un geste en plus
existe depuis deux ans elle organise des
événements pour récolter des fonds et
financer des projets pour aider le
handicap et son insertion
cette année le projet est axé sur
l'accessibilité pour financer un monte
personne dans une piscine piscine de
saint cyr qui accueille des enfants
handicapés il ya un maître nageur qui
fait des cours pour enfants handicapés
et on aimerait l'aider dans cette
démarche en finançant se lève personne
on y est
alors et devinez
plusieurs associations ont suivi
l'initiative d'un geste en plus
proposant aux enfants en situation de
handicap et leurs parents de s'essayer à
des cours de country et pour les plus
téméraires des baladins bouton arrêt
n'est pas plus beau qu'un sourire
c'est vrai qu'il faut être honnête ce
sont des enfants avant tout ça nous
touche énormément et de devoirs qu'ils
sentent bien qu'ils sentent comme tout
le monde qui voit là bon c'est juste
fabuleux quoi
c'est la deuxième fois bgg peu j'ai eu
peur au début et après trajet de taper
la discut vous ai discuté avec mme oda
l'association renouvellera l'événement
l'année prochaine pour récolter encore
plus de sourires
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce journal avant de se
quitter toute l'équipe souhaite bonne
route à isabelle carré aux causes qui
s'envole vers de nouvelles aventures
et on souhaite également la bienvenue un
petit nouveau venu du sud également
félicitations à la maman
la belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]